vous pensez bien qu'on va pas vivre
comme ça avec ses vagues de
contamination avec des coups d'angoisse
des coups de terreur sur la population
moi ça me fait mal quand je vois des
pauvres gens dans la rue ou dans le
métro terrorisé terrorisé vraiment avec
le masque regardez les autres personnes
comme étant des ennemis moi je trouve ça
terrible en tout cas c'est pas ma
manière de concevoir ni la vie ni la
médecine je suis pas un père fouettard
de la médecine
Brigitte au 30 qui a pris la direction
donc du coaac qui a succédé le comité
d'expert qui a succédé au Conseil
Scientifique dit dans les colonnes de
nos confrères du JDD qu'il faut
s'attendre à une augmentation des
contaminations vous pensez que c'est
raisonnable une augmentation des
contaminations rappelez-vous sur splato
dans les tribunes du Figaro combien de
fois j'ai répété dès le début de la
crise ont 1 on va vivre avec ce virus
deux fois arrêté de regarder
l'indicateur des contaminations mais ce
qui est important c'est de regarder les
hospitalisations et on a la chance
j'avais employé ce mot là la chance
d'avoir au micro-ondes qui est quand
même un Variant beaucoup moins sévère
troisièmement on a la chance d'avoir un
vaccin notamment bivalent donc il faut
protéger et insister sur la vaccination
des plus fragiles et puis après il y a
un équilibre qui va se faire mais bien
sûr qu'on va avoir une augmentation on
ne peut pas arrêter ce virus
c'est-à-dire ce virus il est
malheureusement il est plus épidémique
il est endémique il est partout il est
ubiquitaire donc bah il faut pas qu'on
panique à chaque fois qu'on a des vagues
de contamination qui nous dit le seul
problème se situe au niveau des plus
fragiles c'est ça oui bien sûr comme
avec la grippe comme avec le pneumocoque
comme avec tout un tas de virus ou de
bactéries donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
protéger et encore une fois c'est la
vaccination c'est les gestes barrières
mais il faut laisser vivre les gens
autour et c'est même une chance pour les
plus fragiles de laisser vivre les gens
autour c'est-à-dire qu'il faut arrêter
de culpabiliser et de vouloir aseptiser
le milieu c'est impossible on protège
les plus fragiles le virus va samoindrir
avec des variantes qui vont fragiles
doivent laisser les gens autour les plus
fragiles doivent se protéger et les gens
autour il y a un équilibre qui se fait
avec le virus et
qui s'en sortent c'est que du coup le
système immunitaire c'est plus fort
exactement et donc du coup va faire
probablement monter le virus c'est ce
qui s'est passé vers une forme affaiblie
puisque encore une fois quand le virus
mute il s'affaiblit parce que il essaie
de se répliquer un peu rapidement